[Music]
this
is star talk and i can't do that without
chuck knight chuck
hey neil with me with me on this yeah
yeah whatever these are so much fun and
i got a segment here it's on the
space-time continuum
all right that's i'm i'm cool with that
you've heard that
you've heard that you're kidding me it
is only
the premise of every freaking sci-fi
thing ever
yes yes i just wanted i just want to
ground it
in a few ways that i don't think people
spend time doing
so let's let's think this are you going
to ruin space time the week no no
pluto is that what's going to happen
right now nothing i can do can help
pluto just so you know
it's out of my hands so
here we go um 1905 you should know
immediately one thing should know
in your head 1905. einstein comes out
with this special theory of relativity
this one's right okay it's not what he
called it it was
the paper that delivered it to us is
called on the electrodynamics of moving
bodies
and no one wanted to recite that so just
called special
relativity but that's what it is because
it's all about
the relativity of motion and time okay
so what it did was codify
the fact that
that spatial dimensions need a
for the three spatial dimensions you
know height width and depth need a
fourth dimension to localize it in
any spatial system you're talking about
and since you needed time then it's a
space-time
system so
so it sounds like it's weird like what
are you doing einstein you know leave me
alone with my height with and depth
but it turns out we have always thought
about life
in four dimensions always
and here's an example of why if i say to
you
chuck i'll meet you tomorrow morning at
10 o'clock
i'll say great what are we doing i'm so
excited to find out
okay i love when you surprised me like
this well okay okay i can do that but
i'll say
all right that's fine i'll meet you at
the corner of
5th avenue and 34th street okay
what's your next question to me and when
because i don't want to stay there
all day waiting for you so you knew that
giving you
those coordinates right earth surface
33rd street
5th avenue 34th street you knew that's
insufficient for us to actually meet
absolutely you're going to say when a
bing the time coordinate just got
slapped on there
did you just bottle bing space time
i did i did bada bing space time all
right awesome
uh you know is that is that forgivable
to you yeah i think yeah
all right so and you can reverse that
right i can say
uh chuck i'll meet you at 12 noon
tomorrow
okay and your next question to me is
when or where
i just said when okay where where
exactly
so we cannot meet
unless the spatial coordinate is
specified
and the temporal coordinate is specified
oh and by the way because we're all kind
of stuck on earth's surface if you want
to do the full up three-dimensional
meet in space i would say i'll meet you
at 50
at fifth avenue 34th street 107 floors
up
okay or 86 floors up that would be the
empire state building because that's the
coordinate of the
empire state so i give one dimension the
other dimension and then a height
dimension those are all three dimensions
often you don't give the height
dimension because you're just meeting on
the street
right it's just implicit yes we're gonna
meet on earth's surface
this time right right that one is an
easy one to just accept
as a given but technically if you wanted
all three uh
if you wanted to do it full up you give
three dimensions earth's surface
34th street fifth avenue and
at a time so we already knew this
but no one thought about it that way now
here are the consequences of that
if you're crossing the street and then a
minute later
a truck cro go drives down the street
for you were in the same place as that
truck
right when you were in the middle of the
street at the right time though
i was in that same place i mean the
right time meaning that's not where the
truck is at that time
exactly yeah yeah so i'd want to say you
were in the same place at the wrong time
you're in the same place at the right
time right
so so off we are always in the same
place
as each other but it doesn't mean
anything until you're there at the same
time
so i just want to drive home that
concept so now let's go to sci-fi movies
uh how about back to the future one of
the greatest sort of
thought through time travel stories
there are
uh including the terminator i think
thought through time travel very
hard yeah they did did all right yeah i
have an issue wait i
have an issue um with with arnold
um i would
i'll tell you dude he goes back in time
to
kill uh the the possible parents
of john cody the leader of the of the
new
uh movement of the resistance but all he
had to do
is prevent his
the parents from meeting each other i
mean you can go back four generations
earlier and just
put two people on a different train so
they never meet and that entire genetic
lineage never exists
right so this idea that he's gotta kill
them and it's gonna be all bloody that
made it like a violent movie
but it could have been done a little
more with with less blood and gore uh
where was it oh so here's what you have
to be concerned about let's go to
back to the future when uh marty
yeah give me some doc brown here marty
it's
it's time no now i'm in the mood thank
you
all right get the call marty
so so there's marty and he's being
chased by the libyan terrorists
okay that's right uh that's right and
in the parking lot in the twin pines
parking lot all right
and then he he he there's a date in
there from 1955
and he goes back in time to 1955.
okay and he lands in the twin pines
ranch because as we know
all good farmland becomes strip malls
right in modern times all right okay
uh what they didn't address is
the fact that he would only land in that
ranch
if he goes back to when
earth was in the same place in its orbit
he would have to be traveling on the
anniversary of the date that he was
that of when he left so that earth is
back where it is so that when he goes
back in time
he doesn't end up suffocating in the
vacuum of space
oh man that first of all would be the
best
time travel short film ever
i discovered the secrets of time travel
right get in the car
[Laughter]
so i'm just saying it's not good enough
just to travel back in time you need
something to
propel you in space as well so it's a
space
time a space time machine not just a
time machine
because earth is a moving target
i just want to make that clear that's
really cool actually
and by the way just you go back in time
you could still land on earth but how
was earth rotated
you could end up in siberia in the
middle of the ocean probably
because most of earth longitude is
spanned by ocean
um so so i i just wanted sort of
it's truth in time travel with regard to
these
space-time coordinates now um we call
these
your coordinate in space and your
coordinated time we call that your world
line
really yes that's a cool term worldwide
so your word line is where and when you
are
live so you can step back and look at
everyone's world lines and the world
lines are sort of
it's think of it as some kind of shadow
moving
through this hyper coordinate system and
so that way if
i had to go to even a higher dimension
so i can see your entire world line
if i see your entire world line you are
always being born
you're always living out your life and
you're always dying right because i can
see the time
right the whole timeline is there in
front of me right and i can see
other people's world lines intersect
your world line oh that's when you met
your wife
okay that's when you were in my office
and we recorded that episode so
so imagine this spaghetti picture
of all these world lines of human beings
interacting
this is cool and that i don't think
i don't know that anyone has actually
thought to portray that no
they have not that's why i said this is
so cool because first of all
first i've ever heard of it but secondly
that
is something that nobody's put in sci-fi
in terms of actually i take it back
there
there's a couple star trek episodes
where they play with that
but they don't present it that way they
still present the linear
uh as portrayed in different positions
exactly so anyhow so that's that's how
that works and one last point in
kurt vonnegut's novel slaughterhouse
five which
ostensibly takes place in at the end of
the second world war
um and there's the other sort of
historical details i won't get into
what i was most intrigued by is the time
travel that goes on in that and he
actually captures that accurately
so what happens is the lead protagonist
gets abducted by aliens
gets put in a cage and that sounds bad
but they said no you're still there
you're still being
born you're still dying and they went
outside of his timeline
and so he would sit there and daydream
but by daydreaming he
was living his life and he could relive
his life multiple ways and in multiple
times
wait just real quick because we're
running out of time dr manhattan i
forgot also
is the is a character who
lives in his world line and also
sees his world line simultaneously
okay this is uh uh of the uh dr
manhattan from
uh the watchman watson correct yes yes
yes
excellent yeah he's that's a pretty
powerful guy yeah i mean once you have
him what why
have anything do anything you know
that's what i don't like that's why i
don't like watchmen
believe it or not for what you just said
because it's like i got dr manhattan
i mean i'm done here my answer to
everything is like
seriously bro i got dr manhattan yeah
that's the answer dr manhattan it's dr
manhattan it's over
the whole thing so now one other quick
thing all right um
if you have an ant in a in a square
okay and let's say there's a sticky
edge on the square that's basically a
prison for the ant
you could tell me an ant just go up an
inch and out and over no but the ant is
stuck in two dimensions
the two dimensions of the paper that's
at length and and a width
okay or height or whatever those two
dimensions the ant is stuck
if he had access to the if it had access
to a third dimension it could escape the
prison
right right because it could find height
and escape right so think about it
if you are in an actual jail cell
and you had access to a fourth dimension
a fourth spatial dimension you just have
to step out of the spatial into the
spatial dimension and step back in
and you just walk out of the prison
without ever
touching the walls okay so that's how
you escape prison just invent a fourth
spatial dimension to do that
so then i thought if you need a spatial
dimension for that then what about our
fourth time dimension
like why can't we why can't that work
for us the way a fourth spatial
dimension
it does it does here it is you ready so
somebody put you in jail
and now you enter your fourth time
dimension
you go to it return
to your time dimension before you were
put in prison
right now you're not in prison you just
escape the prison and you do it or after
you escape
so that it works the same way as the
spatial dimension
if we can invent that but i'm just that
that's all i got to say about that yeah
a better thing would do
would be to return to before you
committed the crime and not
committed oh reverend chuck
the moral of the the moralist reverend
chuck
all right all right chuck we gotta uh
quit that oh that was great
yeah so this that's uh another explainer
space time continuum neil degrasse tyson
keep looking up
you